- I know that I've talked to
you about your album a lot.
I know.
- You can keep going.
I actually enjoy it.
- You probably think
I'm psychotic at this point
(laughing)
Literally every time I see him at the show
I'm like, "Dude."
I was like, "I can't."
And this is a testimony, I told you this.
- [John] Do you have a favorite song?
- Oh my gosh, I mean,
I love "Wild" actually,
which you're gonna be performing today.
- Yes.
- But "Favorite Place",
I'm really into "Ooh Laa"
I really love, I love the whole album,
"Conversations in the Dark"
I love the whole thing, it's so, so great.
- Those songs are kind of sexy songs.
- Dude, I know, that's what I'm saying.
(laughing)
This is a testament of
how good this album is.
I started the show with saying
like, "Hey, my personal life
is kind of like, ha ha."
(loud huff)
And so, I'm just saying,
if this album can be so
great for someone like me,
that's really wanting some Joni Mitchell,
Alanis Morrisette at this point.
- Yeah, yeah.
- Like it's a great album.
- Well, thank you.
I truly, you know, we
all work in this business
and so, we can be a
little jaded and cynical.
- I know I'm never like this with albums.
- And for another artist to
actually care about your music
and listen to it and love
it and really pay attention,
it really does mean a lot.
So I am truly grateful
for your compliments
and they're not getting old to me.
- [Kelly] Okay.
(laughing)
you're probably like, "Calm down."
It just makes me happy, I love it.